ah
[Música]
i
tras las elecciones ecuatorianas y la
llegada de un nuevo gobierno de derecha
el presidente guillermo lasso se maneja
con mucha cautela el país vive todavía
una luna de miel en espera de las
principales decisiones del primer
mandatario la polarización política en
el país ha disminuido y el correísmo se
ha diluido pero no ha desaparecido
porque no se han tomado decisiones
importantes después de su victoria con
un margen estrecho el país espera
conocer sus decisiones relacionadas a su
promesa de campaña de aumentar el
salario mínimo a 500 dólares el
incremento de los combustibles la
reforma la ley de educación para
reformar el código del trabajo y la
reforma a la ley de comunicación no
queda claro todavía cuál será su nueva
política económica tributaria y exterior
mantener el ritmo de la vacunación es
fundamental para cumplir su
principalmente de campaña de vacunar a 9
millones de personas en sus primeros 100
días de gobierno tampoco se conoce cómo
se traducirá el acercamiento con el
fondo monetario internacional- un
gobierno basado en acuerdos para
gobernar con poco margen de maniobra en
la asamblea nacional donde no tiene
fuerza parlamentaria por lo que el
gobierno de guillermo lasso deberá
mantener la paz social en un país hasta
ahora expectante
[Música]
el izquierdista pedro casi o un virtual
presidente electo que no puede ser
proclamado mientras el tribunal
electoral no resuelva las impugnaciones
presentadas por la derechista keiko
fujimori quien no acepta su derrota e
insiste en exigir la nulidad de miles de
votos son los rostros de un perú
polarizado calles y plazas son tomadas
por ciudadanos de un país dividido en
defender los votos de castilla y
fujimori respectivamente en la
confrontación de peruanos campesinos
indígenas y amazónicos que quieren un
cambio de gobierno y exigen el respeto
del sufragio a la clase política y
económica que ha gobernado por años al
país y se resiste a dejar el poder en
medio de esta polarización ex altos
oficiales en retiro de las fuerzas
armadas sin exhibir pruebas afirma que
existiría un súper show fraude electoral
e instigan a la rebelión de las fuerzas
armadas y a la sociedad para no
reconocer a pedro casi o como presidente
de los peruanos
[Música]
en colombia más de un mes de protestas
han vuelto a evidenciar la profunda
polarización del país manifestaciones
masivas evidenciaron que las clases
populares muy afectadas por la pandemia
tienen reclamos contra la política
económica del gobierno la violenta
respuesta gubernamental que ha dejado
muertes y desapariciones contribuyó a
radicalizar las posiciones parte de las
clases más altas tildaron a los
manifestantes de vándalos y guerrilleros
y las imágenes de civiles armados
disparando impunemente en cali contra
indígenas y otros manifestantes
levantaron las alarmas una opinión
general sin embargo cada vez más
consenso la desaprobación del presidente
duque en el 76 por ciento según una
encuesta reciente mientras los
seguidores del derechista ex presidente
álvaro uribe buscan un candidato para
las presidenciales de mayo de 2022 al
otro lado del espectro cobra peso la
figura de la izquierdista gustavo petro
sus contradictores lo tildan de chavista
y se prevén de nuevo unas elecciones muy
polarizadas
[Música]